hey youtubers is charlie happy Halloween
this is going to be my doctor who
episode 7 video this is another
two-parter just like the Maisie Williams
episodes just careful for spoilers if
you haven't seen the episode yet there
was a whole bunch of classic Zygons
stuff unlike the Daleks there haven't
been a ton of zai gan episodes so
there's not a whole lot of stuff to
refer to so anytime the Zygons are
around there's a lot of unit stuff Ian
they refer back to Terra the Zygons the
classic who episode but knew Brenda the
giveaway starts now to all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber and leave
a comment on this video it's just a
twenty-dollar amazon card so starting
with number five explaining what the
hell's going on with the big prelude
it's almost like doctor who is turning
into a clip show but essentially the
prelude to this was a clip show for the
50th anniversary to explain how all the
Zygons got planted on earth and then for
series 8 to explain what happened to
real osgood and wise igon Osgood is
doing this so for some reason you didn't
see the 50th anniversary in the wake of
that 20 million Zygons basically just
went into witness protection so to speak
on earth the two Osgood's message here
basically explains that there are good
Zygons they just want to live there life
out in peace they don't want to cause
anybody any trouble and then in this
episode we meet the bads icon faction
the radical faction that wants them to
be able to live as they normally look
they don't want to have to blend in so
that's the big point of contention you
have a bunch of different zai gan
factions most of them are relatively
peaceful these two twin girls were like
the old high command on earth but the
radicals icons are like screw that we
want our home we want to be able to walk
around looking like we're supposed to
look so there's any confusion real Ozma
the real Osgood died during series 8 she
really is dead this is Saigon osgood in
the big WTF twist that kind of ties in
with the ending is the Zygons don't need
to keep the people that they're doubling
as alive they used to be that they had
to keep their double alive so that means
all these people in pods including Clara
they can kill them off as soon as
they're done getting the information
they need from them on the number 4
divide and conquer so the episode gets a
little sprawling early on and everybody
splits off into different directions
Kate Stewart goes to Truth or
Consequences turns out Clara plays a lot
of Trivial Pursuit the doctor and
Rebecca front go to the rebels icon base
and then there's Clara's group which
goes underneath her flat eventually
one of the most interesting things I
noticed was when Kate went to the
Mexican town we heard that police
officer that we met speak and I couldn't
remember the last time I heard an
American accent on Doctor Who except
maybe during series 6 like a ben browder
kind of had an American accent Matt
Smith spoke with a fake American accent
so that's about as close as I think the
show has gotten in recent memory if you
guys can remember the last time an
American actor was on Doctor Who
speaking with an American accent let me
know I haven't watched the entire run of
the thick of it but it was fun seeing
Rebecca front and Capaldi together again
if doctor who weren't such a family show
I'm sure we would have heard way more f
bombs on the number three Kate Stewart
knows about some secret zai gan weaponry
that the doctor had stolen from them so
she references terror of the Zygons
that's the 70s 80s icon invasion she was
talking about there's a bio weapon that
can take out a bunch of Zygons but the
doctor took it to keep them from using
it to keep the humans from turning into
the villains and now in this episode
we're building towards these like two
extremes where you have the extreme
Saigon rebels that want to get rid of
the human race then you have Rebecca
French group that wants to new call the
Zygons but the problem is and it's
definitely highlighted by a car at the
end of the episode is that nobody knows
who's the Saigon and who's a person so
the doctor can't let Rebecca front nuke
everyone because she might be killing a
bunch of humans to and in he hates the
idea of killing in just in general on
the number two though huge easter egg
moment this is just actually really fun
Osgood and the doctor talk all about
question marks so this is like a Seventh
Doctor thing the Seventh Doctor wore a
question mark jumper and had a question
mark umbrella so when Osgood was wearing
the question mark that's what they were
talking about but the fourth the fifth
and the sixth doctor all had question
marks on their collars so you could also
look at it more as a reference to them
with the question marks another collars
as well as the Seventh Doctor with
question marks all over him but then
when the doctor says I'm wearing ?
Underpants and she says that begs me to
ask what is the question so it becomes a
funny sexual innuendo but it's also a
Matt Smith think the final question that
that was all tied up in bringing the
Time Lords back during matt smith's
final episode during the Christmas
special I love the even zai GaN Osgood
is a doctor fangirl but finally on my
number one WTF moment the Zygons have
replaced all the humans in the UK the
first battle is won now the war begins
me
meaning they're going to take the rest
of the world seeing evil clara was kind
of fun in this actually this shot of her
with the rocket launcher that was in the
first trail that they posted back during
comic-con obviously this is a two-parter
we know the doctors going to escape he
always escapes but the more interesting
twist i think is what's going on with
kate stewart because zai gan clara
radios her thinking she's calling that
others igon they're asking if unit has
been neutralized Kate Stewart pretending
to be a Zygon I think says yes units
been neutralized brogan the twist i
think is the kate stewart had a way to
take down that Saigon so this is the
real Kate Stewart just pretending to be
a Zygon she's one of those characters
whose just a little bit more clever than
everyone else and not afraid to get her
hands dirty if you remember back to the
50th anniversary she was ready to nuke
everything in the black archives so she
probably has a couple cool tricks up her
sleeve but let me know in the comments
what did you think about the evil Clara
twist at the end I feel like this is a
good halloween episode just because the
Zygons look a little bit scarier and
that the horror is is that everyone has
already been replaced the battle has
already been lost so definite bonus
points awarded for dropping this episode
on Halloween I don't know if they
planted that way in advance if there's
any other easter eggs you guys spotted
in the episode that i didn't mention
like you know ? stare the Zygons fourth
doctor stuff just right and below in the
comments but congratulations to last
week's giveaway winner James Logan you
and a Tony Lara amazon gift card just be
sure to private message me on the back
end of my channel so I get your contact
info what's going to happen next is I
have an arrow Constantine trailer video
that I'm going to post later tonight
hopefully you guys have an awesome
Halloween I'm fully moved into my new
apartment I still have like a bunch of
junk that I need to rearrange and stuff
but i will do a room to her video as
soon as i get all like the furniture
arranged and everything is all organized
so why you guys wait for all that stuff
to post you can click here for last
week's Maisie Williams episode and you
can click here for the flash trailer
video that I just posted explaining zoom
and doctor light thank you so much
watching everybody high five and I'll
see you guys tonight
you